well Norman I think made the interesting
point the businesses were didn't like
change and were were were protective I
mean one of the observations that I
would have around the businesses that I
speak to every day is they're absolutely
committed to making a success of brexit
and that the the decision has been taken
and it's all about getting the best deal
the the the things that they are most
concerned about are continuing to have
barrier free access to the European
Union
about skills and talent and also about
there being a smooth transition
it's often been said particularly by
those who voted leave that business
people are still trying to fight the
referendum again is that a fair
criticism it's really the comment I
didn't I think I have not had that
conversation once with the businesses I
speak to businesses are practical I
think they always knew that this was
going to be a decision taken by the
British people we at the CBI we made the
economic case but we never aligned with
a campaign we always understood this was
a decision that was going to be based on
factors that went beyond economics so
the conversations that I think
businesses are now having are around
what does the plan look like what does
the new brexit deal look like but how
helpful or otherwise is it when we see
companies like Nissan going into number
10 and seemingly getting special
treatment doesn't that play to the
narrative that business is somehow
asking for special treatment from
government I think the most important
thing is that all businesses of all
sizes across the country are listened to
because we really are in unprecedented
times I think the coming year is even
more significant than last year in terms
of the decisions taken and it is going
to be about collaboration between
business and government across all
sectors and all sizes of business so
that's what we need for the coming year
so there is no case so far as you're
concerned anyway of businesses trying to
be nurse made it through this process
I don't think so what I see actually is
a is a government that now is that is is
is engaging very well with business is
listening to all sorts of different
voices I think many ministers are
traveling out of the country we are very
much making sure that the voices of our
members are being heard
and I think that's very positive so the
most important thing is the decisions
that are taken over the next year are
based on evidence and real on-the-ground
experience practical business experience
and what about the attitude of consumers
this year in households are you
surprised by some of the findings in our
our survey where it seems that one-third
of people expect their household
finances to deteriorate this year I
think it's been a very interesting year
in that consumer spending has held up
well our people have been dipping into
savings and it's been a very it's been
we've seen some good economic outcomes
at the end of 2016 there are headwinds I
think we know that there are going to be
headwinds we're going to begin to see
inflation coming in to higher import
prices we are seeing the impact of
uncertainty on business investment that
came through in the last quarter of last
year but I think the key thing is how we
now manage those uncertainties and we'll
be looking to the the budget to see how
the short-run uncertainties are managed
but crucially I think it gets back to
the best brexit settlement and also a
modern industrial strategy to address
the productivity issues in the UK do you
worry that there is actually going to be
a realization when article 50 is
actually triggered at the moment we're
in a sort of phony war situation and the
article 50 when that's triggered that
will be the reckoning where people
actually think
crikey this is going to happen I think
hopefully we can avert that if there are
very clear clear negotiating plans and
that's why I think it is very welcome
that the Prime Minister has said that
she is going to set out her plan a set
of objectives I think it could can also
be averted by a strong budget we will be
putting our submission in to the
Chancellor very shortly and also going
back to this this business this real
opportunity for a modern industrial
strategy addressing the issues around
skills innovation our education system
that we know have been deep-seated
issues these are the things that will
make a that will help to avert the the
effects of the uncertainty